we're told this is the graph of y is
equal to three halves to the x and
that's it right over there
use the graph to find an approximate
solution to three halves to the x is
equal to five
so pause this video and try to do this
on your own before we work on this
together all right now let's let's work
on this
so they already give us a hint of how to
solve it they have the graph of y is
equal to three halves to the x they
graph it right over here and this gives
us a hint and especially because it's
they want us to find an approximate
solution then maybe we can solve this
equation or approximate a solution this
equation through graphing and the way we
could do that is we could take each side
of this equation and set them up as a
function we could set y equals to each
side of it so if we set y equals to the
left-hand side we get y is equal to
three-halves
to the x-power which is what they
originally give us the graph of that and
if we set y equal to the right-hand side
we get y is equal to 5 and we can graph
that
and what's interesting here is if we can
find the x value that gives us the same
y value on both of these equations well
that means that those graphs are going
to intersect and if i'm getting the same
y value for that x value in both of
these well then that means that three
halves to the x
is going to be equal to
five
and so we can look at where they
intersect and get an approximate sense
of what x value that is and we can see
it at least over here it looks like x is
roughly equal to 4.
so x
is approximately equal to four
and if we wanted to and we'd be done at
that point if you wanted to you could
try to test it out you could say hey
does that actually work out three halves
to the fourth power is that equal to
five let's see three to the fourth is
eighty-one two to the fourth is sixteen
it gets us it gets us pretty close to
five sixteen times five is eighty so
it's not exact but it gets us pretty
close and if you had a graphing
calculator that could really zoom in and
zoom in and zoom in you would get a
value you would see that x is
slightly different than x equals 4. but
let's do another example the key here is
that we can approximate solutions to
equations through graphing
so here we are told
this is the graph of y is equal to we
have this third degree polynomial right
over here
use the graph to answer the following
questions
how many solutions does the equation x
to the third minus two x squared minus x
plus one equals negative one have pause
this video and try to think about that
when we think about solutions to this we
can say all right well let's imagine
two functions one is y is equal to x to
the third minus two x squared minus x
plus one which we already have graphed
here and let's say that the other
equation or the other function is y is
equal to negative one and then how many
times do these intersect that would tell
us how many solutions we have so that is
y is equal to negative one
and so every time they intersect that
means we have a solution to our original
equation and they intersect one
two and three times so this has three
solutions
what about the second situation how many
solutions does the equation all of this
business equal two have
well same drill we could set y equals to
x to the 3rd minus 2x squared minus x
plus 1 and then we could think about
another function what if y is equal to 2
well y equals 2 would be up over there
y equals 2 and we could see it only
intersects y equals all of this business
once so this is only going to have
one solution so the key here and i'll
just write it out and these are
screenshots from the exercise on khan
academy where you'd have to type in one
or in the previous example you would
type in for but these are examples where
you can take an equation of one variable
set both sides of them independently
equal to y
graph them and then think about where
they intersect because the x values
where they intersect will be solutions
to your original equation and a graph is
a useful way of approximating what a
solution will be especially if you have
a graphing calculator or desmos or
something like that